[Music]
was a book to an episode of honest
trailer commentaries and guess what
we're talking about a movie guess what
movie it's fallen Kingdom Jurassic world
of dinosaurs I did not plan this by the
way Oh coincidence yeah it's like a one
in three chance JA Star Trek yeah guys I
think this isn't gonna have too many
different opinions at this table we all
hated this one yeah not a fan now yeah
it was aggressively dumb the action was
either not as promised or just not cool
enough to justify it yep
characterization not present dinosaurs
technically present yeah it's just
stupid and gosh I mean I this is a tough
one to write because you just want to
tear into every little minut detail
because we could just go scene by sea oh
yes that's too many darts too many dark
with it but Danna you're just saying
beforehand that you hated this one but
not as much as the first one so me
there's little disagreement there well
this one for me was just so there like
who I was gonna describe like it's there
like can we totally mission in the
trailer so we've made a billion dollars
like of all the movies that made a
billion dollars worldwide this has got
to be up there in the top five of one
that just came and went with like no
cultural impact whatsoever it's like
people just sort of like lemming marched
into the theatre sat down watched it
march down completely forgot about it
like you never heard they hear this
movie referenced you never hear anyone
talk about the fact that it came out
that it exists that there's a line or a
scene or like it's like this movie just
sort of happened to the world White has
just right under your body yeah you did
see all those uh those Maisie cosplays
at Comic Con opened Maisie everyone was
you know you saw this everywhere you
know even like like it's not just like
minions head that like that obviously
the cultural impact that even like Alice
in Wonderland
had a bigger cultural impact than this
movie it's just like maybe that's why I
just I completely this movie would be
worth getting mad at cuz I watch them
just like this is stupid it was dumb and
I don't remember anything about it
where's the other one I thought was so
aggressively just unforced errors and
just like Sherman doing for stairs true
and this one it I think it did miss an
opportunity to go full stupid because
they were tiptoeing with a premise and a
world with the last two of them where it
is full die no writers where they are
yeah Jurassic world war where they're
splicing humans and dinosaurs together
and sang them into Afghanistan they've
been sort of saying that that's a plan
just give us just give us if you're
gonna do it like I guess I'm more
interested in that than just a mediocre
down the middle tentpole with this so
everything's so generic but then they
have like a like a taken auction in the
middle of it yeah makes zero sense but
if you're gonna be the kind of movie
that makes zero sense just go crazy go
full out with it which they end right as
they're getting to that premise we talk
well yeah I take I take issue at the
ending which we didn't get time to hit
in the trailer which is the sense that
this is some type of you know world
ending Cataclysm it's not it's 15 20 all
female dinosaurs like cut out in like a
completely controlled environment of I
guess Northern California yeah well we
got shipped off remember they some of
them got boughten and immediately one or
cargo detonators yeah I mean these are
things that we've seen get you know
tranqued get shot get hurt like this
isn't the end of them this isn't Planet
of the Apes unless they also have a
virus yeah it was it was just so there
was something about like just blue being
the only Raptor looking at a suburb and
then Jeff Goldblum being like welcome to
Jurassic world and it was like a kind of
kind of well speaking of which a little
dramatic jagged we didn't have time for
this in the trailer and Dan I think you
mentioned it his tiff Goldblum
testifying for the entire length of yeah
that's why I don't yes he's wearing the
same clothes and at the beginning he's
specifically testifying about the
volcano erupting but then at the end
he's saying what oh he's saying the same
room
yeah people he's talking to her dress
the same so it's like they tried to wrap
around his testimony like like he like
it's like oh you thought at the
beginning of the movie he was testifying
about what was about to happen but no he
was testifying about what already
happened but no he was specifically
referencing events in the front of the
movie so either he's psychic
and he knew what was gonna happen
because they put his testimony at the
end or everyone just dressed the same
everyone the third one if they're like
Malcolm's in it again and he's
telepathic like if he if they just go
full steam controller swords with his
mind yeah with the go and weird we
talked about it on it could have been
worse when I did this one but like the
concept art for the human Dino Hybris
exists or it's insane
and just go for it why not yeah just do
that movie there was one little Goldblum
ISM that got cuz you know he's in it for
like a minute maybe and it's all set up
it's all trailer lines in setup but I
loved that he got one Goldblum ISM in
the movie because he's like what I think
should be done with our these amazing
beautiful dinosaurs it's like you can
see like that's the one like improv that
they let him keep it's like a beautiful
amazing dinosaurs yep there you go as he
advocates for letting them as he
advocates for letting em all die stupid
movie let's watch our stupid trailer
about the stupid thing
[Music]
just when you thought the Jurassic
franchise couldn't get any dumber Alan a
sequel ensuring everyone still cleaning
out of course an original rap humans
seem stupid yet back for more huh
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom awesome so
I just realized
kicking off the movie my wife had never
seen it and we watched it over the
weekend and 30 seconds in she's just
like why doesn't the submarine have
sonar with the giant Megalodon swimming
behind the beginning there's so many
dumb things yeah just just the opening
alone is that sorry back for more huh
just triggered more angry and me they
didn't check to see if the Megalodon was
like in the area they just went straight
for the course it's got to be an easy
thing to find it's probably the size of
a nuclear submarine and and how did it
survive the gates the gates were closed
yeah so it was in that thing right yeah
we saw in the first movie that for a
snack for like a this is the scene by
scene thing we could do for the Suey for
like a trick it eats an entire shark yes
yeah that's what that's a snack for that
thing and yet it has been inside this
enclosed thing for three years and you
like eat the fresh corpse in its tank
yes still later like gottsy indominus
rex I guess it's skinned it somehow but
left off the bones there's like a like
an ear of corn but did that one thing
sustain it like for three years cuz they
walk in and they're like don't worry
anything that it's in here would be dead
by now and the guys like okay but then
it's not but then I'm like but no he's
right it should have opened should have
been dead just like one seagull did like
did all of the dinosaurs one by one like
wander by that one spot by the tank for
the first movie that just jumped out and
ate all of them individually it's a lot
of new boyfriend's taking their
girlfriends kid out for a hang gliding
oh yeah a lot of that now the question
that raises is so who were those guys at
the very beginning they worked for Wu
okay cuz they needed to get the bone for
the indominus rex to make the Indo Rex
now if there were enough people
interested in dinosaurs that there was a
international trafficking
that you could set up filling a mansion
full of it why would none of those
people just go to the abandoned dinosaur
island for three years and just maybe
pick up on their own basic threat they
seem to have a lot of money to throw
around they could have just gotten a net
in the helicopter and taken back their
own Raptor people just kind of come and
go the Costa Rican government in the
world of Jurassic Park is so negligent
if that place is the hot spot animal
rights place you'd think there'd be like
a million activist groups just staring
at it
I don't ring them both seven blackfish
yeah what are you guys doing with that
little sub being activists yeah go on go
ahead in yeah sorry we'll never get this
keep playing well yeah I've had returned
to Isla Nublar
Isla Island a place two different
dealers pizza and park without sharing
and it was on top of a volcano now after
the original park was destroyed and the
park they rebuilt was destroyed what's
left of that parse Lenny destroyed
unless another billionaire can build a
new dinosaur island and start the cycle
all over again because when it comes to
Jurassic Park dumb fines away
meet another flock that guy was John
Hammonds partner for four movies well
well they they they separated at some
point because of the writer well not
prior to the park because he said this
is another scene by singing he said that
his daughter visited the park a long
time ago
so they hadn't fallen out you know they
hadn't followed her partner's undress a
point during construction of the park
when there was a a park there
the daughter visited but then the
somewhere in there the daughter died and
then he wanted to clone her and then he
and John fell out so my guess is that he
was just in another room for a horror
classic very very silent billionaire
yeah yeah and then once John Hammond
died he didn't you know swoop in and
like do his vision it was like miss
Ronnie here that other guy yes took up
the mantle yeah he was just hanging out
even though there was an original Co
billionaire who also wanted to found
dinosaur human they started it in that
basement which was converted to dinosaur
pens without him know one thing that I
am cured
yeah his own home yeah go ahead Jeff
because I was trying to figure out how
much time took place between Jurassic
Park and this one so I looked it up on
the Jurassic Park wiki powered by fandom
and I noticed that in that Canon like
there's a ton of stuff that's not in the
movies so like I guess it's from books
and comedy so I was like is this guy
from the expanded JP universe like true
JP heads are like yes that guy I only
got him my other shoe wait is he I don't
know oh my like the so the fallout the
the flash point of them not working
together was he cloned a person his
daughter so what we're saying is John
Hamid was like you have crossed a line
I'm gonna go back to working on cloning
vilasa [ __ ] claws and you bring your
daughter back to LA sprinkle in a little
tree frog and a little
electric eel human yes you go do the
thing that everybody wishes they could
do and bring a dead relative back to
life and I'm gonna go make monsters you
monster
I'm going to I'm going to make a
recreational Dilophosaurus yeah good day
sir and this guy well we'll talk about
later here keep eat another flock of
one-dimensional morons some new some
familiar like Claire the caring animal
activist or Owen the cold-hearted
mercenary blue is alive you're just
gonna let her die well yeah and if
you're wondering why their personality
switched in between films Hey look over
there it's Jeff Goldblum you like him
right reel has these only heart is it to
keep your characters wait when the one
character trait well but she saw that
one sick dinosaur that one time on the
last Island okay that maybe almost sort
of gets her to begin a path to becoming
that person she how devoted her life to
a higher life the lives of animals that
history has shown now four times in this
new earth belong extinct yes Chris Pratt
who spent his whole life raising and
caring for and loving and protecting
these animals is like screw it
you know why whatever okay so if your
argument is the events of the first
movie changed them out I'd give you that
if they dealt with that at all in this
movie like if anyone pointed her once
and was like isn't it [ __ ] that you
do this like you were the executive lady
that called them all assets like yeah
you're full of [ __ ] I think somebody
half tried to do it but then they're
like lava and then I was like oh you
helped create these Claire but that's it
yeah like she should be the she should
be getting side ID at that Greenpeace
office like constantly and just the
assumption that anyone in this universe
or the next cares about will they or
won't they at this point god I want to
know I want to know at what point in the
writers room they were like listen their
chemistry and their love triangle their
love arc was so powerful the first movie
Oh
yes again people are gonna be asking why
aren't they still kissing yeah yeah the
moment they sat at the bar and he's like
so you date and I was like we did three
years ago and it happened the same way
they get together then they're not
together and they talk about something
in the past you you would let me drive
the van well you don't want it over [ __ ]
and then they get and then they forget
about it and then they kiss for no
reason at the end when there's like
dinosaurs flying around and then they're
together it's like do you just did the
same shitty thing if just as shitty
again the second time they forget it I
am mad at this movie yeah yeah yeah you
can't write like a good cheers level
where they will they won't they don't do
it because it gets to the point where
it's like oh their relationship is
abusive and now I don't want to watch
them at all like that's that's where
their example we want to make the
cheering when they finally kiss because
they like oh oh that's right they're
supposed to be together in three more
weeks he's gonna shout at her because
she touched his steering wheel or
whatever the hell had a ball it's like
the the lines she is kind of like you
know well mannered and keeps herself
together and he's like I'm gonna live in
a van and build my own house by the lake
and in the third movie it's gonna be
like like why do we break up again it's
like remember I wanted to build that
third bedroom for my big-screen TV and
you wanted a but Bonnie lab she's like
oh like I only need like Oh typical man
with your big screen you know you didn't
want it for that you wanted it well what
it's oh god shut up it's gonna be two
hours of dinosaurs and then they'll kiss
again and you're just like no and I'm
also like why doesn't one of them have a
friend who like sits them down as like
Claire stop it stop it I think we talked
about did we talk yet about the new the
new characters the with Franklin and and
bad we're almost yeah right thrill as
these old favorites are joined by
all-new dinguses like we could work a
paramilitary guy to replace the last
paramilitary guy who replaced the last
guys replace the last paramilitary guy
see a half-baked clone of all the other
kids in the franchise literally a loose
collection of nerd cliches and Xia this
spunky is a veterinarian who's never
seen a dinosaur before wait really you
studied I know medicine while the park
was open to the public and not only have
you never seen one you never thought
you'd see one what oh I'm vet school fax
you would agree why bring you instead of
a Fed who actually worked at the park
and why did this movie make a billion
dollars but look over there there's the
car from the first movie so I guess it's
a wash that was that line I never
thought I'd see one before is an example
of something that drives me crazy which
is when there's a script and whatever it
goes through revisions or the used
characters or some other character
probably said it whatever no one's
paying attention and it's a line that
like it sounds like it belongs in that
scene like looking if you look at that
so it's like what would occur what would
a character say it's like I never said
I'd see one before there's a lot of
people that would say that it makes no
sense for that character I'll say that
wine she's a paleo veterinarian and if
she devoted her life to the science of
being a veterinarian for dinosaurs it
makes no sense for that character to say
I never thought that I would see a
dinosaur in a place where Jurassic world
has been open for so long and through so
many iterations the board with and you
know attendance was dropping you work at
a company whose only purpose is to save
the dinosaurs it makes no sense there's
you would not think that you would see a
dinosaur enjoy so she's a grad student
PhD Gretchen she doesn't have a lot of
money she didn't have the funding or
ever but I never thought I'd ever see I
never even imagined so I would ever see
a dinosaur in a world where dinosaurs
existed I study dinosaurs so and I work
for a company that's going to save and I
heal multiple dinosaurs in this movie
that I guess I practiced on really
lifelike dummies are people here's the
thing whether you could afford to go to
Jurassic world later or not what is the
point what's what is that schools
program if they're not just partnered
with Jurassic world to teach people how
to be vets like veterinarians don't
practice on stuffed animals to get their
degree you have to at some point in your
training
intern and do something with it so it's
like in the writer
they wrote Z on a whiteboard and they
were like for the next 30 seconds
nothing you say is wrong for their
seconds it's all good and everyone's
like bouncing and they're like she okay
okay okay she's like she's like a
Greenpeace gay veterinarian it's like
okay cool rad rad bro you're gonna cut
the game in post but go ahead go ahead
go ahead and she'sshe's really like
sharp-witted she's gonna stand
toe-to-toe with that Ranger guy like
okay okay okay and she's never seen a
dinosaur and someone's like okay Dave
alright I like where your head's at what
else we got and she never thought she'd
see a dinosaur shirt
oh no I that's a line that used to be
someone else's character yeah entirely
maybe her girlfriend no and then they
just like just me crazy though it
happens all the time where it's just
like these these scripts are written and
rewritten so many times it doesn't make
sense for characters to say certain
lines and they just and wind up with
certain just like yeah that's what
that's like that's what I expect just a
final classic way someone just attention
there's good people that are saying
you're doing things that make some kind
of sense given the reality that that
movie itself is present yeah that's what
I expect and this is an interesting
example of a movie where I do think that
reading the news about oh they cut out
the her gay arc or that aspect of her
character probably caving international
pressure like being cowardly and and and
erasing something about the character
that would have otherwise been
interesting after seeing the movie
probably wouldn't done a great job I
promise you it was one line it was like
yeah well my girlfriend said different
that would be the only tip of the hat
like that's character development in
this movie yeah we cut that one line
yeah it had been like Beauty and the
Beast not Gaston oh yeah well ooh laughs
ooh yeah yeah the big much ado about and
what is it just like spinning dances
with the guy yeah that's what no that's
not character developing or this movie
would have just done something real
weird like Chris Pratt just keeps
calling her butcher or something and
you're just like come on
that stupid sam raimi zoom on the guy
he's like what a nasty woman camera like
because the Smith gets wasted cuz that
nerd is the dinosaur jr. to look at with
all in reverence get turned into Looney
Tunes this is we didn't add music hybrid
and director cheese part Raptor and part
indominus rex which was also at the
harbour no Karen thanks mrs. a human are
like scary parts Raptor and she'll kill
whoever you can point a gun at and
trying to respond to a pulse coded laser
targeting system but if you're confused
as to how that's more efficient than
just shooting someone look it's an oil
painting of John Hammond does that still
do it for you poncho the same writer
that added she never thought you'd see a
dinosaur added also you have to point a
gun at the thing and then it'll chase it
like the same dude did that yeah it's
it's just knowing that somebody would be
asking the question of like how do you
control a weaponized dinosaur and the
answer they come up with was well you
shoot it at someone you know what it
reminds me of you watch the office well
sure yeah
you know when Michael Scott goes to
improv class in the only that he has
movies like they only had one solution
to everything which is like hey he has a
gun I also love that we played it in the
Looney Tunes montage of that scene where
Buffalo Bill wants a 2 for 2 from the CI
thing in the Raptor and out of
absolutely nowhere all chaos is breaking
loose everywhere else this is a military
man of action who would have lots of
things to do in this situation he's like
[Laughter]
why I love this movie finally you're
feeling my pain on these things this is
how I this is worse than the other
they're wearing this many moments in the
last one oh my god I
one thing I do want though is between
this movie and Independence Day
resurgence I want oil paintings of
former cast members in every show
because there's an oil painting Will
Smith and Independence Day resurgence
still visit the oil but you still say
there's an oil painting of jet that
needs to be how they bring back
characters I agree every franchise
revival movie has to have 15 oil all oil
paintings of former this is our Princess
Leia room Jimmy Smits oil painting yep
yeah that has to be the way they do it
from now on yeah God good true but yeah
it's just it's just taking your idea and
then just adding and at you you just
took a step too far because they even
say in the movie they're like you you're
the Godfather of Raptor control and
Raptor research and you did this and
it's like so you don't need the gun they
figured out how to do this math wiki
thing man no but this was a prototype
who knew there was this whole fukaku
thing but you need blues mom blue two
blues blood to be the mom so it'll
imprint on blue because only blues blood
blues blood has me we just figured out
Blue's blood has the like the DNA in it
to obey humans even though he just
trained blue right well and here's the
other thing is the endo Rex is a mix of
the indominus rex and a raptor which
anti-feminist rex was a t-rex already
right and a raptor and also now that's
all gonna chameleon a frog of the
chameleon and then he's like well I need
blues blood to train it to be docile and
then she's like yeah well I put t-rex
blood in there so now it's a sock drawer
and doctor who's like you monster how
could you do that it's like no the thing
that you want to put it in already has
t-rex why are you this is anyone paying
attention to anything that anyone says
in any other part of this movie no it
doesn't it's just he needs to be upset
why I don't know what's scary but I love
that the t-rex is only thing to do in
this movie is to just sleep in a cage
yes yeah and just do the roar over every
time it wrong every time it's on stage
it has to do the on stage on camera yes
it has to do the triumphant Jurassic
Park roar
I just want I want someone to add a
banner every time Falls yeah well then
they come in and they do the you know
the replay the moment of the t-rex
coming in and grabbing the dinosaur the
little corn thing and then you know it
comes in at the end it's like it's a
monster at the beginning but it's a hero
in the middle but then it's a monster at
the end again but then it's a here get
your story straight all right keep going
enjoy a feature-length homage to the
other week follow-up to a Jurassic Park
movie the lost world were an old cast
member this is summoned to the estate of
an ailing original park founder same
thing sent to the island to save the
dinosaurs only to get double-crossed by
a slimeball jr. exact ha secretly hired
a hunter to bring the Dinah's
so there's one other thing that I want
to just rant about briefly that we did
we couldn't make it in which is the
ailing Park founder who'd the plant I
assume in universe his plan actually was
to evacuate yes the dinosaurs to a new
sanctuary yes where no one would touch
them where no one would touch them like
at the end of the lost world right at
the end of a sail that did not work he
delegates this plan to his assistant to
such a degree that the actual plan ends
up being kidnapped all the dinosaurs and
sell them in the basement of his own
home without him noticing until the
night of the auction like he was never
like I never checked it in like hey
how's the dinosaur rescue plan going
like yeah why are you hiring so many
military so many done why are there 15
semi trucks back me up well this new
hole we've built outside what is the
evil scientist dr. woo keep coming in
and out of my happiness
that guy's a monster yeah seems like
there's a lot of construction going on
in the basement also that yeah I don't
think that giant gate wall was there
when she visits in the beginning now he
also a I don't I don't remember building
an auction house yeah in my domicile I
know I'm not as mobile as I used to be
but an elevator
yeah house construction goings that
junior executive who I've met years just
a few years prior and it's entrusted my
entire life's work with completely no
I'm not CC done any emails what
expense reports come on that I guess I'm
that removed dice soundproof shuttered
bedroom with Mike Levin granddaughter
all day and trust everything will work
itself out ask questions just why why so
many Latvian arms dealers coming over
tonight those are some Daniels swarthy
Belgians walking in and out from my
window and that I see
did you see their convoy of Ducatis
going through my driveway I see it out
the window I'm sure they're just dirty
balls dinosaur rescue island I know look
through this book of photos of my
daughter healed same boy why did she
know to grab that book when she runs
away dead body in the original draft
someone had just written I'm a clone on
her forehead and she looked in the
mirror like that's a little too on them
I'm literally getting lightheaded from
this here's the other thing I'm sorry
this is the longest common to every but
here's the other thing one of the dudes
from Hot Fuzz he was really funny
it kills the he doesn't plan to kill
James Cromwell that night I get it he
finds out what's going on he's like I
got I thought I could hold the option
you know did you ever notice jack [ __ ]
the jig is up
so he knocks him off he's dead in the
bed okay I'll get it I know you're going
yep he goes downstairs the auctions
going on he comes back upstairs night of
the auction the night of the auction
till dinosaur pilot ABS old dinosaurs
being sold simultaneously he comes back
upstairs calls the maid in or the the
housekeeper in and goes I gotta let you
go he's like and he's like so you'll be
leaving now it's just like what and it's
like why I get what he had to kill him
why would you come back and tell
somebody would happen and like it cuz he
has a conversation about the clone it's
because it's because the little girl has
to be in the dumbwaiter to overhear
what's going on and then figure out
what's happening again
there's no his to-do list should not
hide it
the nanny yeah and I can do easily
tomorrow morning I know we're talking
about Cromwell like just not noticing
anything because he never leaves that
room that lady's all over that house
generally the auction in the prison yeah
she definitely saw all of that and he's
just like you need to go and she's like
okay and goes directly to the Oakland PD
or whatever's closest to where they are
in the bay and is like I'd like to
report a murder probably and also a
mysterious like our like animal sale
also a cloning maybe that would make
more sense if that's like his ex-wife
missed out firing herself in back into
his life that would explain why she's
there anyways I'm sorry weird an hour
into this this is so are we home yet no
it feels like the dinosaurs only to get
double-crossed by a slimeball junior
exec who secretly hired a hunter to
bring the dinosaurs back to the mainland
for profit but while lost world during
the third act into died Godzilla fallen
kingdom limits all the action to the
inside of an old man's house and then
ends right when it gets interesting
oh no look out all the acts in the
trailer yeah this is really just a
trailer for the next movie inside this
movie so get ready to suspend your
disbelief and over the flow of oxygen to
your brain for the best reason since
book of Henry for keep on Colin
Trevorrow five hundred yards away from
the Star Wars script at all times and
finally bid farewell to your Jurassic
Park fandom as it slowly over Hank Lee
choked to death by the smoldering ash of
the thing you once loved quick to the
Brachiosaurus from the first movie
that's the same one but a great nod oh
we could be murdered yeah that's cause
that was completely unforced that was
literally like the movie was out and
then like the director it was just like
okay just eggs you put in there those
the Brachiosaurus from the first movie
without real poetic like you twisted
bastard you're sick you are sick
also it would try to swim it would try
to not get covered in lava
- but I'm sure the dinosaurs are such
bloodthirsty monsters in this universe
that they are trying to eat people and
each other while they're being chased by
lava animals yeah little Satan sorcerer
accident care about the lava bombs fall
and he's like oh I'm gonna eat that
generous lava burn the top of its head
off this plastic kids are gonna get away
with it yeah well I'm going out with a
full belly roll tape roll tape or a
redhead Redemption Indiana groans and
the temple village oh right the total is
all right Lord plot would of devising
ham billy quizboy and emerge the
cowardly dad it puts the dinos in their
pen or else it gets the hose again fun
for the whole family and 30 minutes of
Goldblum's time 30 seconds of actual
movie and 30% of the misleading trailer
the blend before time
I had to bear life like me what'd you
ever watch a movie and know exactly
where and how they reverse engineered
something that flatpoint and yes I knew
watching the movie I'm like yeah okay I
get it they had to a head to up they had
to find somebody who would be so
massively stupid as to actually push the
button and let those dinosaurs ago after
even for this franchise they were like
none of our existing characters will do
that it's just too much and then they're
like okay but what if the kid does it
well that seems too convenient why would
a kid do it okay what if she shared
something in common I don't know what
could it be
she's a clone now if she had looked to
the camera as she did when she said that
line and then her eyes turned into like
reptile eyes okay wait wait wait wait so
first someone points the laser gun at
the camera yeah burrows through his
chest yes could have fixed it there's a
few things you get it done you have any
deleted scenes anything we story yeah
clear and present danger fourth best
Chris and fall a crazy rich Asians I
think I'm a cool now James cromwell's
British accent just some business about
the century that's all
James Cromwell British accent life
teaches us some very hard lessons
storage wars in the binary IT Claude and
inconvenient to
again should have listened to escape
from volcano dinosaur island I quoted
mention - yeah
what do you is so in conclusion what do
we say to the people who say just turn
your brain off it's entertaining cuz
people found it entertaining they're out
there they thought that there was a lot
of dinosaur action and that's what you
bought a ticket for or power to you if
you can completely turn your brain off
that's fine I can't I don't go in
looking for things but I cannot let
logical inconsistencies and complete
ineptitude just to me it's it's a
balance you have to strike because like
I thought the last xxx movie was super
fun yeah that's because it had a
self-awareness about itself it knows
yeah that that followed through from the
characters to the plot to the action
itself where you were willing to suspend
your disbelief in other words turn off
your brain yes when he was somehow
skiing down a jungle like an explosion
out of an airplane and jumping out and
jumping out of it like sleeps this fur
coat and sleeps with four women yes I
understand what this movie is yeah the
thing that irritates me about just turn
off your brain is that the reason you
like movies and stories is your [ __ ]
brain like that's what your your brain
is excited by questions and and goes oh
you know and process a story like as
your whether you're aware you're doing
it or not that's what your brain does
when you watch a story so yeah get you a
movie who can do both yeah case in point
dress yeah yeah know if you like this
movie that's fine I'm not gonna say
you're wrong but you know I just hate
when I don't like something in the
response it's like shut up and like it
like that's not it I can't just do that
yes okay yeah oh yeah no yeah you're
right I will well it made a billion
dollars so I'm sure we will see you guys
soon three five years old Trey Jurassic
Park six Jurassic world three three
hundred mention four
so that's gonna be a like by the beach
this time I think yeah anyways we'll see
you sooner than that next week
where will the three of us will be here
but we'll also be alone mmm
unaccompanied a few else another synonym
for those words yeah thanks for watching
we'll see you next week
[Music]
you